[Applause]
[Music]
today we are in the car Nick and I are
heading up to Vallejo California just
outside of San Francisco six hour drive
so we've got a lot of driving ahead of
us because we're attending slang sense
from our friends over at flight-test
whoo instead of prevent that we're going
to they actually put on every year and
this is the first year they're doing on
the west coast so we're like hey we
gotta go what are you most excited for
it's like those for sure
so they have a bunch of these like group
flights that we can say a word
dozens of people can fly their drones or
planes all the same time it looks like
so much fun and I really wanted to
participate with it but the problem is
that the gentlemen I have I haven't been
able to finish building because I wasn't
able to figure it out so hopefully our
friends over at flight test will be able
to help me get that together that I can
actually participate in this group
flight hopefully not crash I'm pretty
sure there will be someone there that's
called my main help me out
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's often the bestop saying hey looks
like you guys in one second tell you
what's going on then make it feel like
on you're hitting your head get off me
so let's go be more than though the
hallways they push it back down we shot
the entire fight scene here is fastly
good it's like three pages fighting and
it's actually been night never you
adapted to the new pace for you well
we're cranking through it as fast as we
can tops are calling for Nora good
gotta go for a good night yeah and for
here
[Music]
a pilot look at the balloon I have no
idea where to go I think we go in that
big hall you sure look I'm just trying
to find anyone I reckon as well all
right good to see you again good to see
you
we should present an episode this dude
named is crazy like giant c-17 oh you're
gonna see all time too crazy
transmission yeah yeah drop this off you
want to come the whole like vision
behind the flight just in general as we
are trying to get as many people in the
Hobby as possible yeah me and the
hopping people have been modeling for a
hundred years and the reason why it's
like never been really like kind of
mainstream is because of how
unapproachable and like overwhelming
it's always been before the internet
were before you like you go on YouTube
and look up how to do stuff you had to
like know an old-timer at the flying
field it was not only there but also
willing to give you the time of day
everything we sell stuff that helps
people you know getting the Hobby have
success totally so like these planes
these are all of our designs and it's
all made out of like foam board from the
dollar store so like everything's common
materials it's like barbecue your
popsicle stick hot glue but that way
when you're flying you know and back
your head if you pile drive this thing
on the ground
right you can salvage electronic and
then build a whole new different one
that's even if these things breaks yeah
they're really durable too but yeah I
feel like this is the flood I'm pretty
laid back compared to most our student
safety is obviously a number one
priority but you know than that pretty
much anything goes we tell people when
it comes to flight fost and the
airplanes you don't because more than
likely you're not going to come home
with your airplane just the airspace
maintains a pretty chaotic atmosphere
too I actually really do love an outfit
comment probably my other favorite thing
is just seeing all the all my goodness
gracious
Kuzco weird echoes from the world that
plane is called a guinea pig that's one
of our designs and sometimes they fall
out of the track called a game because
people like the experiment with it
climb up Kristen yeah hot blue paint or
and you're literally back in the playful
knows enough boom exact that it's
actually stronger than it was before not
exactly that's the other thing I love
about fly fest today you never know
what's gonna happen
ready and action oops
cut good I'm like just taking a couple
like rolling at motion italics we can do
everything right here we good on book
517 Liberace take one and time
somebody's gonna knock out from me with
a [ __ ]
[Music]
so it's not with presenting chicken
watch
turning running you can suppose never
calls me yes we that slight beat up I
feel like a my people on up in a second
and then he says or not have sense of if
I had a date with my puppy on so perhaps
a bit more yeah Beckett here we go
cameras gonna our action good one more
time
I'm gonna it's good man are you Julia I
know that run ah it was fun it was cool
I apparently forget that I'm supposed to
stop with my right and return that's
acting my friends that's because you
have to anticipate the explosion as
Niko's directed I'm anticipating the
exposure which I don't know about time
travel it's time travel there's a watch
it's not this one cuz that's mine but
this is what we're talking about
what's your name Bob Carmichael
Carmichael cool man thank you what's
your name
go away all day yeah imagine that
but Carmichael's pretty cool too I'll
take that I'll set a good boom wait for
me to come down yeah thank you I'm gonna
be on Nick yeah thank you guys you guys
rock the the flag of the first copter
and all that stuff here music well I
brought my unfinished verse the copter
with me so I'm hoping it's going right I
figure we're gonna get a fly we're gonna
fly do you find a job I thought will get
Ian on a path the people coming from
around the
and they volunteer they get here they're
excited and then they start serve
another tea party they want to be part
of our digital community and bring it
into reality
yeah I think cyber we got to take some
note real things coming down because my
buddies and just being in a place like
this even though I have a drum I'm going
to try to finish building and you got it
a while ago
yeah like over a year ago so yeah we
joke we joke that like one year is like
five years and quads it's like quad
years technology goes potential growth
it's crazy
let's go your quads like five quadruple
will get it flying or maybe I mean you
can upgrade you know yes
Garrett yeah go to your wanna we're
doing this scene where a guys house or
apartment is filled with natural gas and
explodes and there's a guy outside in
the hallway at the door it's swung
backwards into the wall along the door
that blasts into him so we're doing is
rigging up a wire through a hole in the
wall the back of this guy's vest and it
goes to the door so he gets the ain't
door gets yanked whitson because we go
flying into that wall as hard as you can
special effects have had a misfire I'm
pretty much every single effective done
and I can just see it now we're going to
yank the scan the wall to destroy it and
my pair cam doesn't blow better you'll
be angry Nikko a rare angry needle thank
you unfold and if it's awesome is
workable reset would you want more Kenny
to discuss three two one it you can step
one gram is going off for these and
people back and there'll be a cut
bye-bye guys
pictures up pictures up
come on Omar Tom dare you set please
Thanks go on you're gonna see in the
fall three
[Music]
that thing's bigger than I am
I've been riding around the one-wheel
this whole day right and this guy who
has this really really cool c-17
airplane I can't get enough speed just
like having to go down the runway and
it's too big to throw so he saw me
riding around he's like hey you want to
carry it and throw it what do you mean
like I'm literally going to carry it
right down the runway on the one-wheel
and throw it hopefully I don't break his
very priceless aircraft it was very
detailed what we're playing yes hey a
lot of the doctor not specific just
financially my father my dad right there
yes hi he was the head of the structural
tender my mortgage on the roof oh no
kidding and everything I'm proud of my
dad so in orbit like oh right through
and you're trusting me I'm dressed I'll
hold it while riding down the runway to
lunch it c1 launch was yesterday it went
off great but this morning it just
things weren't going right and now I'm
done sorry lanes here so you can't do
any worse than me this morning oh I'm
nervous but I got this I'm talking I've
never forgotten
yeah we won't let you down
great no pressure no pressure at all
three two one whoa okay good all right
Nell step I stay back guys oh no didn't
work we didn't work for the table ma no
I didn't work the door still back then
let's do one more time going through the
door we're not going to put it where I
can lock it in the door we'll go okay
cool and he looked really nice oh yeah
[ __ ] look great what good things
apply would run like that so we can't
it'll have to make this promise the door
flying across the hallway and that's why
I'm going to get like a couple minutes
Ren is practicing I think he's really
nervous we check it out you can is gonna
be flying it is going to get in just
beat up and then Susie start feeling it
take off it will be launched mine just
lets go and then red just let the fly
hold on to it while you're practicing
and then let me know how you feel okay
okay yeah I'll hold it no he's just
practicing good are we a little practice
warm-up that should be good yeah all
right guys thanks patient little ready
to give us a shot we're having to take
out trouble with this beautiful c-17 we
wanted to get some air day or footage of
it so we're figuring it out
[Music]
more tape or glue what happened there do
you think so I mean the wind is really
gusting you've probably thought he had
it here and it you know nothing about in
my hand this is like nothing Oh God
gusty wind it's all right and then he
everything everything was going fine all
the sudden I got a cut I felt it there
was a gusty wind came through it made
the the plane lift I was like whoa and
it kind of caused me was balanced but
then I also kind of thought I was
lifting off so is like ok time to go
I was like ok commit and I just see it
go down like no I do now bragging is in
flux with an action I'll count about it
but this time tries to lighten out that
your feet up and pull those shoulders
better yet let go try to find that
ground plot now so as much as your feet
hitting because that wall
all right guys pictures up let's roll
sound please eight common mark okay
quiet big Jeremy Tommy ready let me go
on a PSP okay please sit back then
okay here we go guys pull like that
there we go yeah I got the door I'm next
some guys going to be throwing out a
fire oh thanks on my planet we drove all
the way up here so I'm hoping that these
guys will be able to help me but it ends
up not working out we will have driven
all the way out here for no reason
maybe no London right now there was no
slow